I'm the most emotional intelligence
there is et chatted with Bachelor
breakout star Corinne elympios right
after the shows women tell all taping to
get her reaction on all the drama that
went down you say everything you wanted
to say how do you feel I definitely said
everything I wanted to say I think it
went really well and I'm very happy with
the outcome so no regrets all good any
of the haters what's your message to
them my message them is that listen I'm
sorry that I did something to make you
that upset but I can't make the world
happy I wish I could but I can't I just
wanted to tell you that I appreciate all
the time that we spend together and it
really was very special and thank you
very much how do you feel about Nick
today and how was it seeing him here
tonight seeing Nick tonight was
definitely a little bit shocking but I
think I got my closure tonight good how
are you feeling about your relationship
with Taylor after tonight how are you
guys walking away whatever it's deaded
it's done there's no turning back right
now but um you know I just feel it was
very sad that she felt the need to play
the victim here when she put a woman
down on the show so early in the game
and didn't even get a chance to get to
know me first and for no reason then you
did nap and then you didn't so I don't
are you not - I literally watched you
nap grow up grow up come on we're
fighting for our fiancee here and
they're worried about next next
[Music]
you